i'm laura ingram and this is a special
edition of the ingram angle
a week in an hour tonight we examine the
stories that made these past few days
from
biden and kamala abroad to fouchy and
the media back home
plus we're going to take a look back at
the big comebacks of the week
from the cinematic to the political
raymond arroyo will explain it rest
assured in friday follies
but first who said there wasn't news in
history made of the g7 and cornwall
who said biden didn't impress the world
with strength
vision and symbolism well
at least one biden did america is facing
a series of real and major challenges
right we have china's
huge military buildup and the crush of
humanity entering our country illegally
and our media chooses to focus on
whether
jill's kind of teen seen love jacket
is really just a melania trump diss i
remember the former first lady wore a
jacket of her own in 2018 that drove the
left
nuts listen it was an excellent troll
by the first lady to melania trump i
think she is sending a message and she
even said this america's sending a
message of love reunification
i'm glad you brought up the jacket it is
very hard to imagine
that that was any sort of coincidence
sometimes our clothes speak for us
well the print headlines were just as
embarrassing
usa today called jill's jacket a
symbol of unity for whom
teen girls who read twilight novels and
cnn claimed
jill biden's love blazer sets the tone
for the g7 summit where's the barry
white music
now the only news to really come out of
the g7 is that our allies like biden as
in joe
more than trump because unlike the
former president old joe
will be submissive and not really
require anything of our allies and of
course
he'll totally ignore america's national
interest
in favor of global concerns so the
entire confab is just a huge waste of
time and
at times just plain goofy right down to
that
awkward walk to the outside platform
so which way are we going we're going
here come on come here
joe you come here jill let's go all
right
now you've got to look at that
photographer in the middle of just above
right above the guy was joe confused
about where to look there
but don't you love the idiotic elbow
bump among
all these people who are outside and
have already gotten the vaccine
it's all team doom has theater at this
point
but the real action this week was not
with
potus but with v potus
kamala harris has finally run into the
buzz saw that she's probably been
avoiding her entire life
it's called reality as in having to
answer serious questions
about a real real problem the border
crisis
which biden foisted on her to address
but instead
it's just become a mess oh and that
rhymes and by the way
harris is showing signs of cracking
this whole thing about the border we've
been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
you will indeed visit the u.s mexico
border and will you do it soon yes i
will and i have before
when are you going to the border vice
president the administration has
asked i'm not finished
i've said i'm going to the border you
notice that she always says that i'm not
finished let me finish interjection
it's sort of like a punctuation mark of
desperation for kamala
well i imagine you were surrounded by a
team of folks that helped prepare you
for this nomination
hearing i have had
but let me finish if you don't mind when
they're instructed once excuse me
i'm asking the questions and i want to
add but if mr vice president i'm
speaking i have i'm speaking
appeal the trump tax cut mr vice
president i'm speaking
the fact is everyone is starting to see
what democrat primary voters knew about
kamala harris back in 2019
she's just not a prime time player she
has no relevant experience
and she's totally in over her head
the president and i also discussed the
root causes
of migration the root causes and the
acute causes
and and deal with those are many factors
at play
when we look at migration historically
and currently the issues that are
long-standing
by virtue of the nature of them are
never going to be solved overnight
we have to
deal with the complexities of this
oh my god it's terrifying that sort of
glib bromide laden series of
generalities
it may work you might be able to slide
by in the u.s senate
but it doesn't work when you're on the
world stage and charged with handling
serious issues
now things have gotten so bad for vp
harris that she even has cnn worried
that was an easy question that was
clearly a question that the vice
president was going to get
perplexing that answer is perplexing she
dismissed it
in a way that was not really responsive
that was not satisfactory a sign that
she has
a learning curve in this new job when
she doesn't like a question that she
gets
she often deflects in a way that can
seem
defensive yeah i think
yet the most significant development of
the week is that it looks like the biden
white house is beginning to have a
growing case of buyer's remorse
about harris it's no surprise that the
white house was not thrilled by that
answer
there are administration officials who
were perplexed
by how she answered questions that they
felt
she should have known were coming
they're leaking about her it's not a
good sign
if the woman gets prickly when asked a
simple obvious question
how the heck is she going to do when she
sits across the table
from let's say her chinese or russian
counterparts how's that going to go for
america
oh okay but maybe we're all being too
hard on vice president harris i mean
the border issue is serious and all but
is it really about life and death
i don't know you be the judge my judges
are asking for one thing in particular i
sit in front of them i go
if i could do one thing for you what
would that be and this is the ask i'm
getting
uh they go tony we need more body bags
and i'm going body bags
why do you need body bags he goes my
they go migrants
are are dying at record numbers and we
don't have body bags
to handle the situation well this is
just one of the many reasons
harris isn't rushing to visit the border
what's she going to say if she's asked
about this
is this okay with her and if not what
does she plan to do about it
last night texas governor greg abbott
stated his view on what their real
motive is
do you believe this is purposeful on the
part of the administration
allowing this many people to come into
our country
i feel certain that it is willful it is
purposeful uh is wanting disregard
for the border laws
the administration here is in a real
bind sure the border is a total
nightmare and everyone knows it and it's
causing biden's numbers on immigration
to tank
but worse for them politically is the
fact that
for every challenge facing america
biden's chosen number two
is simply incapable of doing her job at
the level it needs to be done
so how's this gonna play out badly
that's how
this is what happens when diversity is
valued more than merit and
accomplishment
they had to know she wasn't up to the
task when they chose her
remember this is from the new york times
in november of 2019.
that was their title hers was one of the
worst campaigns in recent memory i'm
kind of paraphrasing the piece
mark by infighting it was directionless
and harris's sister was a meddling
opportunist
it seemed like everyone on the staff was
miserable
if kamala harris belly flops this
spectacularly in her first six months as
vice president
we all better hope that nothing happens
to joe biden in the next four years
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else